hello on vous l'annoncé hier soir
jacques vergès pourrait être à cannes
demain afin de présenter le film de
plots de balle que la vérité est amère
mais que le défenseur de klaus barbie
soit ou pas à la projection du film en
quête qui relate l'arrestation de jean
moulin selon la version de rené hardy le
map pool si vous préférez le mouvement
contre le racisme et pour l'amitié entre
les peuples vient de lancer un appel à
un rassemblement demain à 15 heures sur
les marches du palais croisette c'est à
dire all year i were de la diffusion de
cette production dans le cadre du marché
international du film
en attendant donc cette manifestation et
les autres aspects de ce festival de
cannes
aujourd'hui il a dû se passer pas mal de
choses jean françois téaldi eh bien oui
j'en embarque effectivement l'événement
de la journée aujourd'hui comme vous
allez le voir tout de suite sur des
images de paul fougerolles l'événement
de la journée c'était cet après midi une
conférence de presse donnée par lilian
gish une des stars d'hollywood est allée
du muet une des interprètes favorite de
10 des bénéfices dès 1912
et puis avec la fin du muet l'arrivée du
parlant une semi-retraite les
apparitions avec king vidor en 47 dans
duel au soleil et la nuit du chasseur de
charles laughton en 55
et puis ensuite le théâtre il y en qui
je vous le savez partagent la vedette de
world of goo ce les baleines doutre de
lindsay anderson écouter une des stars
d'hollywood
jusqu'à la fin des années 20 les films
était muet en noir et blanc
les images parlent et par elle même
pour les gens du monde entier c'est
cette extraordinaire voile alinghi je
suis une des stars du muet en tout cas
un film à voir un des très bons films de
cette compétition et puis ce matin
également en compétition officielle nous
allons tout de suite voir un extrait
l'italie était représentée par ettore
scola étant à ce qu'aulas qui court
toujours après une distinction
la familia un film co produit par fr3
avec vittorio gassman net
moi qui ait ou non
une exception millimono la maison et
favorise de la caméra fait partie de la
maison
donc c'est pour ça que je ne pourrais
jamais sortir il n'y a pas d'air que ce
coup de théâtre il n'y a pas de chez les
mâles nous vivrons je crois pas qu'on
dise m et 30 cents par sac à vis comme
tout travail de la terre et fait figure
ici ni par moi j'aime vraiment vrai
caractère musulman je n'ai jamais
disputé avec le réalisateur parce que
j'ai une théorie où on a un mauvais
réalisateur et à l'enseigné de ne pas
discuter de ce pont fait qu'il a un bon
test et l'ecc avait convié la vie s'est
présenté à la fêter la faute et sandra
de la profession qui est pas si celui-ci
année pour possiblement exposés voilà
gassmann sandrelli noiret être escola
autant de beau monde pour un bon film la
familia qui passe en ce moment même dans
la grande salle du palais des festivals
autre film qui passera ce soir hors
compétition c'est le woody allen tout
simplement la lyonnaise c'est l'histoire
tout simplement de la csf dans les
années 40-50 un film intéressant on y
retrouve tous les protagonistes
habituels
le woody allen dans mia farrow